[Music]
many americans are expected to vote by
mail for the first time this november
because of the pandemic
and all across the country the rules
vary for when you can get your ballot
and when you should return it so just
take a look at this in green
you can see states that require ballots
to be postmarked by
election day the yellow states require
that they be received
by election day key distinction for
details everybody should
check with their state election office i
can't stress that enough
very important one other thing that is
very clear you need to give it even more
time than your state might recommend
to get your ballot through the mail
system this is crucial in 2016 out of 33
million mail-in ballots
more than 73 000 arrived too late to be
counted they were not counted
so what we did is we set up an
experiment to see how long
you should give yourself to make sure
your vote actually counts
we got guidance from voting rights
advocates who say it is as simple as
determining how much time it takes for
first class mail
to go from point a to point b
if you know how to mail a letter you
already know
how to mail in your vote
thank you very much but how long might
it take for that vote to actually arrive
and be counted have a good afternoon we
decided to test it sending
mock ballots simulating a hundred voters
from locations all across philadelphia
to a p.o box we set up to represent a
local election office
a couple days later we mailed a hundred
more using the same size
envelopes and the same class of mail as
real ballots here
to approximate the weight we even folded
mock votes
into every one in the following week we
checked our p.o box for the results
mail pickup notice there's more when we
went to collect everything
though
most of our votes seem to be lost
and explain ourselves before someone
finally found
our votes
[Music]
we soon discovered another problem miss
sorted mail
two pieces of it we got a birthday card
from mike
to ronnie have a sweet b
day get it there's a bee on top when the
birthday greetings ended
12 13. we found a bigger issue
21 percent of our votes hadn't
materialized after four days
and the batch we'd mailed a week prior
some of those were missing too
so of our 100 ballots 97 arrived which
sounds pretty good
unless you consider the fact that that
means three people who tried to vote by
mail
in our mock election were in fact
disenfranchised by mail
in a close election 3 percent could be
pivotal especially in what's expected to
be a record year for mail-in voting
we're going to see somewhere between
probably 80 and 100 million voters
receiving their ballot that way tammy
patrick is a former arizona election
official who says many states have
policies
that just don't take into account the
postal system so states like ohio
you can request your ballot on saturday
up until noon
for tuesday's election and that is the
worst possible thing because
you are setting up the voters with false
expectations
and you're setting them up to fail the
postal service says voters should mail
their return ballots at least one week
prior to the due date
but nearly half of all states still
allow voters to request
ballots less than a week before the
election so you can forgive the public
for being a tad confused
how long do you think the post office
recommends about three days two to three
days
they're saying at least a week a week
they're saying at least a week for your
vote
others are hesitant to rely on mail for
something as serious as their vote
do you trust the postal service to
deliver your vote i never have honestly
i don't know if i would
have you ever had anything lost in the
mail i absolutely have
yeah are you waiting on things in the
mail right now i am
i am yeah i just don't trust it now
that's true
you don't dress them all either well i
just don't i would like to give
especially during kobe give them ample
time to deliver it
i don't trust it why not i'm scared that
it might get lost in the mail
i just want to make sure that my vote is
submitted
like i see that it's submitted that it
actually counts in the warehouse where
philadelphia stores its voting machines
we share
the results of our little experiment
with city commissioner lisa deely who
helps oversee elections here better than
you expected it was better than i
expected okay that's good to know
after nearly 15 thousand ballots arrived
late in last month's primary here
she says voters are right to be wary if
i'm hearing you correctly what you're
saying is
even if a voter follows all the rules in
the state of pennsylvania
you still can't guarantee as an election
commissioner that that vote arrives on
time
no because i can i can guarantee my end
of it
i can guarantee that i'm going to get
your ballot and if i get it back in time
it's going to be counted
but i have no way of guaranteeing what
happens in the postal service
think about that for a minute so we
should point out that official election
mail unlike our mock ballots here has a
logo
that we couldn't include that logo is
supposed to expedite things but
our results are broadly in line with the
post office's own audits
the postmaster general declined our
request for an interview but in an email
the postal service told us
it's quote committed to delivering
election mail in a timely manner
and says it can handle the expected
surge and that it is working with
election officials to help
with that effort and to educate the
public but guys gail the
the postal service also says get this it
cannot guarantee
any delivery date with your ballot so
the recommendation
nationally is don't wait get that thing
in the mail early early early
well message delivered tony but i gotta
say for people were
thinking about voting mail and voting i
don't know if i would be no i wouldn't
be comforted by your piece
and number two you said that 97 of the
ballots of of the 100 came back
but you had to ask the postal service a
couple of times because first they told
you
it wasn't there yeah and there are cases
just from this
that's not reassuring there are cases
from just this last spring
where ballots have gone missing and
turned up after the election so it
happens i mean the post office is doing
its absolute best
yeah well three percent doesn't sound
like a lot but three percent of an
election can be
huge can change every sure can all right
yeah